i truly believe that anybody can become
financially free through investing in
property within 12 months and listen not
only have i done this but i've helped
hundreds and hundreds of people do the
same thing too and how they achieved it
well it all started by reading this book
okay i wrote this a few years ago buy
low went high i've lost a little bit of
weight since then in this book
i teach not just the concepts of
property investment but the exact
step-by-step how-to this is like a
how-to guide i mean literally you can
buy a house like this house
this house will rent out room by room
for about four or five hundred pounds a
month okay or you can buy really cheap
ugly houses and get the same rent on
them and in this book i show you how to
buy houses for like a hundred thousand
pounds and how to rent them for fifteen
hundred pounds per month if you haven't
got the money to buy the houses in this
book i teach you how to secure them on
lease option agreements i teach you how
to secure them on joint venture
agreements i teach you even how to
package deals and sell them and
everything is in this book there's a
reason this book has sold
over 100 000 copies in the last few
years there's a reason that this book
has helped hundreds and hundreds of
people become financially free in
property and the reason is is because
this book gives you an exact how-to
guide unlike nearly every single other
property investment book out there
not the best bit is
it's free you can get this book right
now for free as a gift from me to you on
one condition or actually two conditions
the first condition is if you become
financially free in the next 12 months
after this free gift
please do find me on social media and
message me and let me know what happened
and the second condition is the gift is
the gift the book is free but you do
need to pay your postage and packaging
which is just two or three pounds just
so that i can physically put it put a
stamp on it put it in an envelope send
it over to you but the book is free
there's a link somewhere around this
video click on the link i'll send this
to your house personally over the next
few days and i can't wait to hear your
success